previously on TV sins you're like a
wizard I'm a lot a wizard and that's
something good and I'd wager two full
minutes of credits that in by letting us
know that george RR martin used to be a
writer
polo why does it take five cuts to show
this woman crawling through a stream bed
I know editing can create a mood in the
viewer like oh man this Chase is frantic
but don't we already know that when we
see the dogs Ramsay Bolton and a psycho
girlfriend chasing after if they were
this close in the chase that dog would
be chomping on her bones before Ramsay's
bed-warmer could fire sorry
nock and loose an arrow I get the
tension building is important for action
scenes but so is editing also show fails
to include the scene where Pennywise the
clown eats Ramsay Bolton and his
girlfriend that was the centerpiece of a
storm of sorts I'm not saying that the
whole psychopath Ramsay Bolton stick has
gone on too long I'm just saying that at
this point I'm not sure who was
suffering from Stockholm Syndrome or
Theon or the audience this show has made
me really detest sausage in that I can't
forget the dwarf the [ __ ] and the
mother of madness the Lannister berry
tails
there's this night Leigh good
thunderbolts on his shield I'd give all
the sins back for every episode of this
entire show if he was talking about a
Shazam Game of Thrones crossover episode
also your promiscuous woman has the last
name Leigh good really as in lay good
night Leigh good and his lay loving wife
feels a bit lazy if you ask me I hate
her the hand from the Kingslayer
well travels but how exactly does word
travel at least in this instance British
Sherlock didn't send Ramsay a raven and
it's not like Ramsay's had a lot of
company over the last few weeks while
he's been chopping off bits and pieces
of Greyjoy
Theon was a valuable hostage not your
plaything see this is something you
should have raven him about earlier when
necessary the show makes long distance
communication look easy but when
convenient it's never even considered
I'm just saying if you send a bird maybe
Theon would still be in possession of
his Greyjoy's Bolton looks a decent
amount like Stannis Baratheon doesn't I
know one of the last names that start
with B it's as if this show wants me to
fail a test of character names it's
easier to remember who everyone is on
Days of Our Lives I'm sorry here show
just goes from this to this these
bastards have spent the last four
minutes of screen time building to the
shape he didn't shave his mustache damn
it wait actually happened in that scene
nothing important I'm sure
no one weeps for spiders or [ __ ]
that's a rack no sexist also clearly
varus hasn't had the luxury of going
through a few tissue boxes during a
viewing of Charlotte's Web or spider has
my heart may you and my daughter
Margaery drink deep and live long
defined long exactly we now take you
live to bar prepping his summary of the
Moller report there's a ship waiting in
the harbor bound for Pentos
you have your own cabin of course and
across the Narrow Sea a house servants
he literally just found out Shay could
be in danger this morning maybe he could
arrange the ship that quickly but a
house with servants was he Ravens so
help me gods if someone mentions Ravens
you're a whole person it's mean to
someone they love so they will leave for
their own good cliche can't have
children with the hole how many men have
you been with five hundred five thousand
I get that Jay is stubborn and Tyrion
doesn't think she will leave if she
knows the truth but maybe give that a
whirl before playing the sexual history
card how many ships did he bring to your
course
how many men still more than you
Bharathi and burn with literal burning
in the background I'm still sitting it
but that's kind of badass yeah without
Lord now this is all burnt wait did you
see I've never tasted anything as good
as grilled seagull I would like to say
that didn't make me hungry but here we
are you know what I'm just gonna say it
this red priestess is totally going to
lord of the light he'll this lovely
little princesses face I just know it I
cannot wait for that to happen no no no
seven heavens no seven hells do you
imagine it's easy if you try the
religions in this show are fascinating
because the show wants them to be the
cause of so many of the plot movements
what I'm ever really exploring the
history of them the human motivations
work because we understand them but the
religious motivations feel a little
empty there's only one hell princess
going through Carice van Houten
filmography I'm guessing that would be
repo man
I'm sorry is this a vision or is it a
game of thrones Easter egg hunt and why
am I suddenly thinking of the fountain
right now No
dosoo Mississippi wait I thought we were
playing the name bad Rob Reiner movies
game sorry about that
I've seen what feels like 27 weddings on
this pho and I'm pretty sure the winning
guy has to tell you it's time to put the
cloak owner John for his premature
celebrations don't bode well for the
first night with his wife cursed be he
who would seek to tear them asunder did
you see that focus shift during that
line there's something to be said for a
show that knows where it's going and by
George the payoffs in this world or next
level hold on is that ta Curtis oh sorry
crazy which agents flashback why are the
Tourelles walking down two different
roads diverging in this yellow wood when
they were sitting together at the
wedding ceremony you ought to try
enjoying something before you die huh I
wonder if she means shave or taking a
crap maybe I don't know why those two
things under my head but ever they are I
don't know she's there but you but
everyone else is going to know if you
don't stop talking about it around all
these people war is war but killing a
man at a wedding or it what sort of
monster would do such a thing
poison shadowing as if men need more
reasons to fear marriage also don't you
hate it when something like the red
wedding happens and it inspires your
1980s stand-up material and when you try
it out on an audience you find the one
person whose brother got murdered at the
red wedding
okay good very good lost you guess this
might be the only time I side with
Joffrey that god damn you for making me
side with Joffrey my fathers are both
rather keen on the prospect they
certainly are that stays you could marry
and now I just want to see that version
of this show lucky for you none of this
will happen because you'll never marry
and neither will you
Oh incest burn also incest burn is a the
misspelled insect bite remedy beat a
tone-deaf brother-sister band named C
cream you can find in a private room at
your family reunion or deep a clever
aunt aground or cubs intern which is the
first clue and finding the secret key to
the gold at Fire Mountain I don't serve
your brother your grace would you love
him and here's another love triangle to
keep track of only 10 minutes removed
from Jaime chiding Laurus about the same
thing there is so much relationship
bingo to keep track of in the show it's
gone from love triangle to love hectic
on this series has now had at least two
scenes of juggling which is two more
scenes than any show should ever have
and the director said let's have every
single person have an apple at the ready
to throw it this fool so will know
without a doubt that the entire town is
made up of [ __ ] new Tom and who dis
this is one cringe-worthy moment we all
want to disappear from but you guys get
back here and watch this nonsense thank
you now we can be tortured together
since that is what this show is about
after all who knew they had Spencer
Gifts in Westeros I'm not sure if I
should sin how not entertaining this
whole thing is or sadly how much I am
entertained by it this is just like that
episode of The Last Airbender when they
had to watch that play about themselves
except the Tadmor bear a serein wolf
head can you imagine the things Terry
and his had poured on his body this
wouldn't even rank in the top 100 today
so they just switched out who shot JR
with who poisoned Joffrey the show's
fine Dallas with Dragons and incest
that's quite possible Dallas had one of
those things as well holy Sh I'm so
happy to see this horrible person die
totally missed how beautiful Searcy's
Jules look so she's got that going for
her at least I thought it fitting
considering the rocky terrain should I
call you always look on the light side
of line
[Music]
oh not again there's no earthly way of
no
thing is which direction we are going
I'll feel like a tornado in a trailer
park come with me come with me if you
want to live